[Musique]
votre majorité s'obstine à vouloir
maintenir l'article 19 sur le diagnostic
préimplantatoire et la détection
systématique de ce diagnostic accepté
accepté ce diagnostic pour tout les
trisomie et surtout pour la trisomie 21
c'est faire un premier pas et vous le
savez madame busin l'a dit elle-même
vers le tri des embryons
mes chers collègues vous ne pouvez pas
jouer à la roulette russe avec les
embryons vous ne pouvez pas jouer aux
apprentis sorciers sur des questions
aussi fondamentales que la vie humaine
que ce dimanche 26 juillet un petit
groupe d'activistes à fort de france a
détruit aux termes d'un ultimatum d'un
ultimatum si le regard passif de l'état
sur les fenêtres même de la préfecture
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur une
statue de joséphine de beauharnais
comment votre gouvernement avertit par
ultimatum at il pu laisser faire
comment votre gouvernement informé à
l'avancé at il pu laisser détruire un
monument historique se rendant
juridiquement complice par abstention
d'un délit puni de 10 ans de prison
par quelles faiblesses avez-vous pour
annoncer aussi vite à tenir une promesse
du chef de l'état le transport
décarbonée nous sommes pour
mais voilà entre les annonces du
président de la république sur le
développement du train de nuit ou celle
du gouvernement sur le développement du
rail
il y à un gouffre avec la réalité
actuelle
vous en conviendrez pour utiliser les
transports décarbonée il faut d'abord
qu'il existe une offre
le ministre de l'agriculture multiplie
les déplacements et constate le désastre
mais les belles photos les belles
paroles les beaux articles ne sauveront
pas nos agriculteurs n'empêcheront pas
la fermeture de nos usines il ne
protégeront pas davantage nos
concitoyens de futurs importations
massives de sucre produit dans des
conditions sanitaires et
environnementales très éloignées de
celles que vous nous imposez monsieur le
ministre
allez-vous avoir le courage et
l'honnêteté de dire à nos agriculteurs
et industriels que vous les abandonner
ou au contraire allez vous à vous
le courage de mettre en pratique les
paroles présidentielles en permettant
l'enrobage protecteur des semis de
betteraves dès 2021
dans la tente d'une alternative
technique viable quoi que l'on puisse
penser du plan de relance européen il a
fait deux victimes
le fonds européen de défense fixé à 7
milliards contre très espéré et l'espace
dont le budget est passé de 16 milliards
d'euros espérés attrait et quelques ces
mauvaises nouvelles ont pour nous deux
conséquence directe d'une part elles
viennent percuter de plein fouet
l'ambition affichée de l'europe de
conquérir son autonomie stratégique
d'autre part c'est autant de financement
moins pour nos industries de défense et
spatial
ce qui constitue une faute stratégique
et une erreur économique
monsieur le premier ministre je conçois
notre rôle de législateur comme un rôle
d'accompagnant et de facilitateur et non
comme le verbalisateurs d'un carcan
juridico-administratif illisible
incompréhensible injuste parfois jusqu'à
stupide mais toujours prêt à sanctionner
il est en effet essentiel de maintenir
entre autres votre responsabilité
financière en faveur de l'agriculture de
montagne dont le renouvellement des
contrats mlc pour les cinq prochaines à
nous élus agriculteurs de montagne ne
comprenons pas des tergiversations de
l'état qui ne souhaite s'engager que sur
un an pour 80% des quinze mille hectares
concernés
[Musique]